these are pictures broadcast by a
houthi-controlled television channel but
it's clear what happened the building
has been totally flattened
they're picking through the rubble but
by now and with the resources they've
got there is little chance of finding
anyone alive
it was a detention center run by the
iranian-backed houthis but many of the
inmates were civilian refugees who had
been fleeing the fighting
we consider this a war crime against
humanity the world should take its
responsibility at this critical moment
in human history
we are witnessing many victims
the number of dead keeps going up one
local hospital treated around 200 of the
wounded but then shut its doors because
it couldn't cope anymore
saudi arabia which is backed by britain
and the us in this conflict has claimed
responsibility for another airstrike
that hit a telecommunications center in
the key port city of hodeidah knocking
out the internet across yemen
three children playing football nearby
were killed in that strike
the airstrikes are retaliation for
houthi drones that exploded close to abu
dhabi international airport on monday
killing three people
what we need is to stop this virtuous
circle in which things get escalating
one after the other
what we need uh is to have as we have
been
proposing from long ago
a ceasefire together with the opening of
harbor and
airports
and then
the beginning of a serious dialogue
among the parties
this escalation needs to stop
yesterday there were huge protests in
the rebel-held capital sana as yemen
faces yet another phase of violence in
this long-running conflict
seven years of devastating war tens of
thousands dead
and yet still it goes on
aleister bunkel sky news